it's an atrocious situation isn't it K
where 15 million people Thames water
customers that's a quarter of the UK's
population is waking up today not
knowing if they actually have a water
company to provide them with clean water
or not that's terrible I also think it's
it's kind of odd that the government
appears to have left this till the very
last minute before taking action I think
that water companies have a
responsibility but I also think this is
a regulatory failure and it's a system
failure the Tories originally set up the
water privatization so they effectively
privatize the profits and nationalize
the risk and that means working people
are left paying higher bills they've got
sewage on the beaches Rivers they can't
swim in and right now 50 million people
don't know if they'll have clean water
by Saturday so what what does the
government do under these circumstances
it should instruct off what the
regulator to do its job and if necessary
give them extra powers and instructions
so for example off what can already cap
customers bills they should be doing
that they they should also be the
government should be instructing off
what to link pay to Performance I think
everybody watching this K will think
it's unbelievable that there are bosses
of water companies who have been
pocketing billions of pounds and bonuses
over the last few years whilst there is
sewage on the beach and they don't know
if they're going to have clean water by
Saturday that's atrocious and that's
something the the government should be
instructing off what to do so it's off
what also failing well I think off what
needs to take ownership of the powers
they've got and actually use them the
minister so I would like to see them use
the power they've got to cap bills yes
but I'd also like to see the government
take ownership of the things that they
can and should do and a labor government
would do which is instruct off what to
take charge of the links between
performance and pay and would a labor
government take ownership of all of the
water companies well look at the moment
we're in a volatile situation which is
changing minute by minute and I want to
see first what the Tory government
decides to do we we have the you know
International markets to worry about I
don't want to destabilize anything by
making and and advise
um short-term comment I however what I
want to see is the outcome now the
outcome has got to be that people can
rely on clean water coming out of their
Taps that they can rely on clean beaches
and clean rivers to swim in we are an
island nation it's summer we should be
able to think about going to the beach
or the river without having to worry
about our whether or not the children
are going to get diarrhea and that's
where we are right now and it does feel
to me like yet another example of this
country just doesn't feel to many people
like it's working anymore for them talk
to me about this privileges committee
report that we're expecting in the next
hour or so reflecting on MPS that are
supporters of Boris Johnson and speaking
out about the committee calling it a
kangaroo court well obviously I'm going
to be reading the report when it drops
at nine o'clock this morning and until
then I can't speculate on what's in it
but what I do know is what the current
prime minister has done recently and he
appears to fail to take responsibility
he has no comment on the Privileges
committee's report into Boris Johnson
who lied and that's what the Privileges
committee found out now that Committee
Member those committee members majority
of them Tori have been put under
intolerable pressure which they have
stood up to admirably over the last year
particularly around the time of the
publication of their report there were
atrocious comments and certain members
of parliament and others who should have
known better and should have respected
the Parliamentary process but above all
the leadership here is coming from Rishi
soon like I'm afraid to say the only
sort of leadership he's showing at the
moment is weakness we he had time to
wave through Boris Johnson's
dishonorable honors list and he hasn't
got time to think about whether or not
to turn up to vote on the Privileges
committee report or even utter an
opinion on it Boris Johnson lied other
people commented on the committee's
processes in ways that were deeply
inappropriate and the public and this is
why it matters the public needs to know
that if a minister or any MPS there's
something in the House of Commons and
effectively to them that isn't true that
it is corrected and if it isn't
corrected that there is a process for
showing what the minister should have
done that's what happened in this case
but these MPS probably not going to face
any sanction are they well we'll wait
and see because there's various things
that could happen depending on what's in
the report but I will wait and see
what's in the report first I just think
it's a it's it's pitiful that Rishi
sunak hasn't seen fit to support the
privilege committee's work so far
something else that we'll be waiting to
hear keenly about later on today is the
court of appeal ruling whether flights
to Rwanda are lawful
either way the losing side can appeal so
this is just going to go on and on and
on and we have the minister sat there
earlier on and he was very critical of
Labor peers in the Lords who uh he says
are sabotaging the immigration illegal
immigration Bill well an odd thing to do
for a member of a government that
actually has a majority in the House of
Commons and he should know better the
Lords are doing a detailed piece of work
scrutinizing this legislation hampered I
have to say by the fact the government
didn't publish an impact assessment on
this bill until this week and when they
did it contained barely anything it's
almost laughable if it weren't so tragic
what it did show one of the few figures
that was in that impact assessment is
that it's going to cost 169
000 pounds per person deported now that
is simply not cost effective it's more
than it costs to keep people here but
that is also not an acceptable situation
the government has failed to consider
any other option than they are they're
obviously failing Rwanda policy they're
not looking at clearing the backlog of
applications which they should be doing
because people who are here and
shouldn't be should be properly assessed
and returned
they they clearly aren't I mean they're
waiting the waiting list the backlog is
growing day by day as is the bill for
putting refugees and Asylum seekers in
hotels which are not suitable for them
well that's still going to cost us even
more that's going to cost us 169 000
pounds per person that is more than the
cost of keeping them here that's just
not it's less effective if that's if a
percentage are sent to Rwanda well I
looked at the report very very carefully
I read every word and there are huge
gaps in it and that's not really I'm
afraid to say what it says there's in
fact a section on page 14 item 35 in
which it says this may not be a
deterrent at all because Asylum Seekers
having taken many risks to get as far as
that as as as Europe they will try to
get to where they feel safe where they
feel connected and probably where they
speak the language now deterring the
boats has to focus on taking action
against the evil criminal smuggling
gangs and the government simply isn't
doing that if we scrapped the Rwanda
plan we could use that money to put it
into the National Crime agency and
actually go after the criminals and then
deal with the problem Upstream make sure
that we're getting safe and legal routes
sorted out where we can do that and
family reunion but also recognize the
fact that most refugees in the world
stay in their own country or they cross
the border into the next door one and we
need to take responsibility for doing
our fair share because we are part of a
global community and that should be part
of Britain's place in the world do you
think that
um any Refugee migrant will ever find
themselves deported from the UK to
Rwanda it's hard to see isn't it I mean
so far we've got a situation where the
government has has sent more home
secretaries to Rwanda than Asylum
Seekers and it's just it's obviously a
failing system if it's ending up in the
courts but it's also a costly system and
a costly system spending taxpayers money
committing even more taxpayers money on
failing approach which is patently not
working not processing people I know
that from my own caseload as a member of
parliament but the figures actually are
there to show that we've got more and
more people the impact assessments shown
that's costing more and more so the cost
of failure is too high and the cost of
failure on human lives is atrocious and
I think the government needs to admit
that they've made a big mistake with
Rwanda they should cancel that spend the
money on going after the criminal gangs
and sort out the backlog all they
presided over here is completely broken
Asylum system